the fact is with some works of art
created in this Century it can take time
and some imagination to understand just
what you're looking at that has never
been the case with the works of Alex
Katz the prolific painter is known for
the accessibility of his work often
portraying the people he's come across
in a long career and even longer life
Anthony Mason spoke with Katz as a much
anticipated retrospective exhibition
opens here in New York
Alex Katz has been painting for 77 years
now 95 Cat still climbs the ladder in
his SOHO Studio to apply brush Strokes
to his epic canvases a lot of painting
is like a collaborative yeah with the
audience you paint a picture and they
tell you this is what I see and you say
oh well maybe it is
at New York's Guggenheim Museum a major
retrospective of his work just opened
it's only his second in this country the
last was 37 years ago how does it feel
to have a big retrospective after all
this time well that's the only thing
that was missing you didn't think anyone
was going to give you one no there was
out of the question why the lack of
retention in my work yeah is a real
negative thing in New York City your
work has always been very accessible
well I always wanted to make the fellas
I played ball with in Queens yeah could
get the son of Russian Emma Grace cats
grew up in Queens New York so were you
thinking you could make a living as a
painter no I thought I was going to be a
school teacher a teacher and paint them
aside he took art classes in Manhattan
just as the city was changing New York
went from a provincial City to a real
Cosmopolitan place in the 50s yeah and
the art World kind of exploded the oil
exploded and the Poetry world was out of
sight and terrific Jazz yeah
[Music]
what did you take from Jazz well Stan
Getz was the first cool musician I saw
yeah and my work is cool the poet Frank
O'Hara a friend who Katz admired said
his work had an oriental calm it has
these great lines that live with you
forever like I trust the sanity of my
vessel that's it you know in painting
you have to trust trust yourself or
you'll fall into convention and for the
first seven years I didn't know whether
my work had anything you actually
destroyed a lot of your kids I just read
about a thousand paintings you destroyed
a thousand thousand paintings yeah why I
didn't see any reason for keeping them
the technique I kept depending busted up
and threw them in the fireplace in 1957
he met Ada del Moro at an art opening
they'd marry the next year
any intelligent person my age should be
painting abstract yeah and she was right
laughs
his contemporaries Jackson Pollock and
Willem de kooning were but cats believed
art would come back to the figure even
if the critics didn't concur when I got
a bad review I want to come out the next
time and stick an elbow in the
reviewer's face
you know
it's part of the Drive Ada would be his
inspiration she uh is like a European
Beauty in an American Beauty Picasso
would love to paint her she didn't need
Picasso she had you so I painted her a
lot to do how many paintings have you
ever have you done do you think of her I
don't know maybe 500 or something some
crazy number
actually it's over one thousand
cats became fascinated with Billboards
in 1976 he was given one on 42nd Street
they won the live in Uptown Square I
think was huge huge thing it was 250
feet long and 60 feet high I want to see
whether my pains could hold up to a
billboard is there a challenge to
painting this side yeah it sure is
in his SOHO Studio in New York he's
painting on 10 by 20 foot canvases you
work your way up to this oh yeah yeah
well I wouldn't plunge into this
he paints smaller versions first and
Spends months working on the composition
in his head
yeah we have dreams about doing it
another way oh yeah nightmares the pain
not going on right if the scale is
heroic his subjects are not and this is
called grass
can be heroic it's ambitious
[Laughter]
cats tries to paint instinctively faster
than he can think
so if I paint automatically it comes out
pretty good right if you don't think
about it too much is that what you're
saying no I'm just going stroke stroke
stroke yeah and then you look at it and
see well it's like soup it needs more
carrots
in the summer months cats Paints in
Maine which features frequently in his
work I've been working very hard this
summer you have yeah
his Studio sits on land he bought back
in the 1950s what was it that Drew you
to Maine the light was just fantastic I
just really loved it and I thought
painting every day and it was like
really wow a really big kick
more than 70 years later not much has
changed
are you still working like seven days a
week oh yeah I get up 7 30 in the
morning I work seven days a week that's
flat out
I never thought I'd have the privilege
of being a full-time painter
Anthony Mason for CBS Saturday morning
[Music]
kind of fast fascinating that he didn't
get critical critical Acclaim but yet he
was still selling his art and big
projects like the one on 42nd Street so
who needs a Critic I love how much
Anthony was enjoying oh he was that that
was part of what I was enjoying
beautiful like when he says he wants to
give the critic an elbow
right in the face that's right